[Music]
this is a tesseract and that's pretty
much all you'll ever know for sure about
it secret military research facility on
brightly lit exposed Mesa helicopters
did not need to follow roadways Colson
wears sunglasses at night Nick Fury's
character development literally begins
and ends with eyepatch exciting
superhero movie starts with plotting
exposition possibly racist movie kills
two Asian extras in a row tesseract
powers allow for mind control by tapping
the center of the chest dangerous energy
source space doorway with gamma
radiation screw it transport by hand the
pull-up proof vest fake out first action
piece of major super to a film is a
boring car chase scene does not contain
a lap dance Bruce Banner is hiding out
where only little girls and shield can
find him
shield answers to four people on
vertical plasma screens bad guy henchman
running laps Loki's scepter is also a
space phone the Helicarrier is hella
stupid cloaking device is dumb but I
also don't know why they're hiding cap
pays off a bet he never technically
accept we're sweeping every wirelessly
accessible camera on the planet look he
makes grand appearance changes that
barely change his appearance attacks
Germans but lecture Semin English did he
just jump for a plane you know the Nazis
had pieces of flayer that they made the
Jews we're late night kidnapped
brotherly argument on a mountain
superhero pissing contest super villain
prisoner left unattended super hero
pissing contest number two cap and Iron
Man almost kissed mighty Helicarrier
basically neutered by one freaking arrow
clearly no radio in his ear but he
pretends to have one computer virus
delivered by arrow for Super Soldier
Captain America is a terrible shot
Loki tricks Thor with the old Lucy
Charlie Brown football print so Loki's
plan was to get captured on purpose and
then have Hawkeye break him out but no
real objectives long boring fight scene
between characters we are already trying
not to hate tesseract mind-control
powers erased with a simple blow to the
head fury gives intimidating death stare
to a computer screen
dying person can finish their last
profound statement before dying cliche
bad news negates the need for medical
care Nick Fury motivates the team by
lying about the location of baseball
cards cat gets aids from handling bloody
baseball cards basically indestructible
heroes still need little league pep talk
to get up for the big challenge Thor has
trouble picking up his hammer but it's
never explained every gadget in this
movie has to glow with the blue light
Loki patiently waits for Iron Man to
remove the damaged suit grab a drink
banter a bit and then put on a new suit
instead of just killing it
at Loki's mind control powers only work
at the scepter touches the exact center
of a person's chest generic bad guys
soldiers whose abilities and
shortcomings are never explained why are
they even trying to stop an army that we
never once see kill or injure a human
being
Captain America's really more of a super
gymnasts than a superhero black widow
knows exactly how to handle and fire an
alien weapon seconds after picking it up
and suddenly there was Bruce Banner on a
motorcycle production design 101 don't
imitate anything from Transformers Hulk
can suddenly control his powers because
the story demands Thor's lightning turns
out to be really really effective
against the aliens but he only uses it
once the council would rather definitely
kill everyone in New York with a nuclear
weapon then maybe have some died in an
alien invasion
Loki gets caught monologic Nick Fury
fires a missile at an American to stop
him from firing a missile at Americans
all the enemy soldiers die like once the
mothership is exploded there is no
gravity in space but Iron Man falls back
to earth anyway banner and start dating
now credits scene to tease the next
movie turns out to be a homework
assignment for Machine missed by any
movie goer who didn't realize there
would be two end credits scenes so
basically everyone
[Music]